[Music]
hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered i'm peter lavelle
the end of a love story will tensions in
the u.s
german relationship determine the fate
of nato and if elected
will joe biden be america's version of
the soviet ruler
lenin brezhnev
[Music]
to discuss this and more i'm joined by
my guest glenn diesen in
oslo he is an associate professor at the
university of southeastern norway
as well as author of russia's
geo-economic strategy for a greater
eurasia
and in budapest we have george samueli
he is author of bombs for peace nato's
humanitarian war
on yugoslavia all right gentlemen
crosstalk rules in effect that means you
can jump in anytime you want and i
always appreciate
it okay let's go to oslo first uh
there's a lot of discussion about
trump's decision to move i think what
twelve thousand troops out of germany
and the the the the theme is is that uh
coming out of the white house
germany is not paying its nato bills but
that's i'm not
satisfied with that explanation oh by
the way it's bipartisan it's a bad idea
um everyone knowing i know anyone that
knows me watching this program i think
nato should be dissolved completely
but nonetheless glenn you know the the
top line uh story here
is is misplaced this is about a frock
relationship that germany has had within
nato
with the united states leading that
alliance um
since the uh since then the end of
the in in the end of the 1940s all the
way to the end of the cold war in 1991
it so there's something much bigger in
play here go ahead glenn
well uh trump obviously is much is much
bolder than his predecessors but
now you are correct this is something
that has always been
uh yeah some tensions in the
relationship which has always gone on
for example throughout the cold war the
americans were at this
large extent uh concerned about some of
the european integration
and as you remember after the cold war
you had madeleine albright
cautioning the europeans that you know
the eu should not decouple from nato
remember that nato's the main
institutions
now this because well very simply
because
european integration enables this
continent to use collective bargaining
power to
have greater equality in relations with
the united states
so this is quite normal for any country
why would you cooperate with 27
27 countries seeking uh to you know
negotiate from business position of
strength
and they always had the incentive to
deal with one state individual instead
on a bilateral basis and then
maximize their influence however the u.s
has nonetheless
very much supported european integration
at least to a certain extent because
it provides the eu not sorry they
provide the united states with a very
powerful ally
but it's very important to recognize
this dilemma that the u.s has always
faced
so a strong eu weakens the us within the
west
however a stronger partnership with the
eu then
also becomes a source of collective
hegemon in the west so you empower
a strong partner so you can rule
together now i think
now in the last few years this
relationship has begun to change
largely because of the rise of asia with
china at the center because the u.s
wants to spend
less on europe this already began with
obama
however they want more loyalty to the us
in terms of use our energy our
technologies our corporations
our transportation corridors banks et
cetera et cetera so
and on the other side europeans they
want more autonomy
so and at the same time they still want
americans to pay for security
so this is a relationship that's always
been uh
has had some tensions and it's always
been negotiated and i think what we're
seeing now it
has to be redefined and i think it's a
mistake to simply dismiss it as
you know trumping erratic exactly not
saying that it's not erratic
but yeah well i mean erratic i mean you
know you
move the troops to another country like
uh poland okay which the us promised
it wouldn't do at the end of the cold
war also
um i find it really quite amusing that
you know
this bipartisan uh hair on fire is that
you know it's going to cost too much
money to
to relocate these assets here george
they never complain about the cost of
the military when
they're escalating but they do complain
when they de-escalate
quite interesting go ahead george that's
exactly right
it's the the one item in the budget
that never causes any controversy in
washington that's the
the military budget that that just sails
through uh
you know trump proposes 730 billion
uh the democrats say 770 billion you
know aria let's split the difference
let's make it 765 billion
i mean that just it just waltzes through
for all the apparent controversy and the
the
bitter fighting between the democrats
and republicans militaries
and of course in this case trump's um
proposal
to uh withdraw these 12 000 troops um
from germany has indeed been attacked
bilaterally i mean both democrats and
republicans have
condemned uh uh trump's withdrawal and
of course
that's always the case the moment
there's any discussion of withdrawing uh
u.s troops from anywhere so whether it's
syria
again bipartisan hysteria uh
withdrawal from afghanistan bipartisan
history and remember
i mean with the whole story of the
russian bounties
uh on u.s servicemen you know it only
the story only wheeled out uh precisely
at the time when it seemed like great
u.s troops are about to leave
uh so just as the uh when trump wants to
withdraw from syria we suddenly hear
about the gallant kurds
we must save the kurds the kurds are the
greatest ally in the world
so i would expect um at some point
you know maybe next week uh some stories
along the lines of
there's some russian german plot taking
place in berlin
uh putin is engineering some kind of a
major crisis in germany so we mustn't
absolutely muslim uh withdraw any troops
from germany so that's this always fits
into a pattern
and of course you're absolutely right um
with withdrawing
uh troops of germany in fact you know
making steps to
um you know bring this nato this museum
relic that serves no
no political strategic purpose to an end
can only be a good thing i mean
sadly i think we're still a long way
from that but at least it seems like a
step in that direction
you know glenn you know and reading the
main mainstream media press on this
topic here
never once did i come across that public
opinion poll consistently in germany
would like to see the american troops
leave their country
75 years after the the vanquishing of
nazi germany
uh but it's never mentioned in the press
that you know they the troops they're
just not wanted they're not
needed and and really what this gets it
what's coming into for
here in in your first answer was quite
eloquent is that you just have
american exceptionalism against european
ideas of security and and they're
clashing go ahead
glenn yeah well uh the mission
of nato has changed because uh well
initially when it came to place the
whole
argument was that western europe was
very much weakened from the war and the
americans needed to
stay there until they could be
temporarily strengthened and then leave
i mean this was the famous quote by
eisenhower when he was the supreme
commander of nato he argued that you
know in 1951 the argument if we're still
there in 10 years
this whole mission would have failed
because we didn't build up the europeans
and then pull back
well now the situation's changed
radically for one there's there is no
soviet union
second europe is very much rebuilt but
as we discussed before the the key
purpose now is this power structure
which emerged
uh during the cold war which is the the
u.s pace for security and the europeans
largely yeah do us their toll but you're
also correct that there is a discrepancy
between the political leadership
and the population i mean almost every
year they do these polls
uh who's the greatest or where does the
greatest threat to international
security come from and
almost all of america's allies say
united states
so that there is this uh yeah this is
this difficulty
in in the relations now um so i
with the trump argument though i think
within washington you get two different
perspectives one is
trump's argument essentially you know we
have to punish the germans because they
don't do as we're told and if you're
shifting the troops around then you're
essentially punishing them so
from trump's perspective he's actually
saving nato by
having this punishment and reward based
on their loyalty to the united states
it's more from congress
you get this other perspective which is
you know if you alienate
uh you know the europeans the germans
then effectively you're handing them
over to the russians and chinese and
this could be a kremlin conspiracy you
know
it's it's actually very
multi-dimensional because george i mean
ever since trump talked about it when he
was a candidate and now president
is that there's been a theory out there
is that you know
forcing the european countries the nato
members to spend more
um with the nate the these nato members
would realize well
why aren't we spending so much money
because there really isn't a threat
to our security here and that would be a
way for trump to say
see if i force you to pay more you don't
want to pay more then you say
that there is no threat yeah i mean and
and then actually it's kind of
coming to fruition in a very weird way
go ahead george
yes that was the um uh the argument
uh and that's it and that's a very
reasonable one um
which is that uh you know okay you you
telling us
that uh you're terribly frightened
there's this terrible big russian bear
uh in the east uh okay fine
then um pay some more you know you know
why are we uh
protecting you you're the one who's
supposedly in the front line
and so when they say well yeah i know we
said we're in the front line but
we don't actually mean that we're gonna
spend more they said okay fine
and then we're not gonna spend any more
and so that was so
that was a reasonable argument but trump
also had a
a deeper uh argument which is
that europe has become an economic rival
to the united states i mean it was one
thing to
um build up uh you know
europe's defenses in the 1950s and 1960s
but even
from the 1970s on um west germany and
that was called at the time was now
becoming a serious
economic rival to the united states now
you know
45 50 years on we can see the results of
this
and so therefore it does make very
little sense for the united states
to be subsidizing a power that is
really an economic giant i mean this
makes absolutely no sense
uh and trump realizes this but of course
you know there's a huge
powerful uh well-oiled atlanticist
establishment
that is absolutely hell-bent on
thwarting any
attempt to um uh disentangle this uh
relationship uh so yeah yeah they're
just they're just too many careers built
on this okay
i mean and the five thousand uh nato uh
bureaucrats uh on the continent as well
i mean they you know they
that's been their entire future glenn
one of the interesting things that i
find interesting is that
with this i mean the polls want they
want to build fort trump they
they want american troops uh permanently
stationed in poland
again that would be against the um
agreements made
ending uh um uh the confrontation in
in europe with the dissolving of the
warsaw pact um
but doesn't poland stay standing like
this its position
doesn't that really divide nato
internally even more
because it shows that there is no kind
of unified understanding of what the
alliance is supposed to do i mean this
is an alliance in search of a mission
and the polls are stepping up and
defining it for the rest of the
member countries go ahead well
that was already uh a concern by
when poland and the others joined nato
because after the cold war there was
some concern among for example germany
that they didn't want to
pinpoint russia as a threat they
believed that it was able to
find some working relationship with them
meanwhile
the poles pretty much just wanted to be
on the other side of the wall so
continue it as an anti-russian alliance
now the solution for nato what what do
you do with
if the western europeans don't want to
name russia as a threat and the eastern
europeans want to label russia threat
the solution was essentially strategic
ambiguity you know we're just about
democracy
stable government and you know we're
friends to russia and
and effectively the the guarantee was uh
once russia pushes against the
expansionism
then that would trigger uh this security
guarantee in which it converts from
being this organization for democracy
to again containing russia so that was a
strategy
you need huge military budgets to defend
european democracy
i'm not sure i really comprehend that
gentlemen i'm going to jump in here
we're going to go to a short break and
after that short break we'll can you
continue our discussion on some real
news stay with rt
welcome back to crosstalk where all
things are considered i'm peter labelle
to remind you we're talking
about some real news
[Music]
okay george it's it's uh switch gears
here um
none of us are doctors here uh obviously
and
um but we're all perceptive about
politics that's
what we do basically for a living in one
form or another and watching
joe biden i mean it's really it's quite
shocking that we've gotten down to uh a
candidate
that the the the democrats have rallied
behind if tepidly
um that is challenged okay
um uh he's challenged in in a variety of
ways here now we
all know that this is domestically this
is all an anti-trump um uh gambit
that's very very clear okay it's not
voting for joe
it's voting against donald trump but if
we do have this
uh biden administration the implications
are enormous
how would the outside world see this
who's in charge entered interagency
consensus
who's in charge of that i mean it would
send a very ambiguous message to the
international system go ahead george
yes uh that that's uh entirely right
um what's very sad here is of course how
cynical
the democrats have been all of this
after all uh
biden's um physical and mental
deterioration
was apparent throughout the primaries
uh everybody could see it i mean the
candidates themselves
on the stage were seen to be sniggering
at his obvious decrepitude
uh yet they all uh rallied around him
they endorsed him
why was this because they were
absolutely determined
uh to defeat donald trump and they
thought that lunch bucket joe
uh with his supposed uh links to um
the in mid industrial midwest would
somehow
be the one person who could be
absolutely guaranteed to defeat
um trump now it's becoming clear
that this is really very problematic
as people do see him uh that this is
you know how can he last four years let
alone eight years
so who who is going to be uh running the
country now as far as the outside world
is concerned well
there are no doubt the atlantis is
establishment types were very powerful
in europe
who would welcome uh oh it's great it's
the the return of the
uh the obama crowd uh all the all the
safe pair of hands
or or george or or maybe on the flip
side of what you just said is it
an empty vessel that we can fill yes
yes yes that's right so they they're
they that's exactly exactly
they'll tell them oh you know you know
russia's a threat uh you know we gotta
you know spend more here
move troops here you know yeah yeah i'll
go along with all that so
yes no no doubt um uh they're happy
about this
but it's a very dangerous situation
because to have
uh somebody in the oval office who
really isn't up to the job
so he could either make a absolutely
reckless foolish decision
uh or the decision will be made by
people who have not been elected to
anything
um and with their own agenda that's the
point that
you know you know glenn you know
historically we you know we had winston
churchill in his second stint as prime
minister
he was uh he exhibited uh um a mental
deficiencies obviously brezhnev the
soviet leader
uh he he died in power uh and even
ronald reagan in the waning days of his
second term in office it
became became obvious that he was having
some problems as well
now i'm describing three individuals
historically
three important historical individuals
at the end
of their uh government uh power service
okay we're talking about a guy that's
going in
to the white house i mean that should
send up alarm bells
shouldn't it go ahead i guess that's the
key difference that it's not at the end
of his term
uh i i agree with what was said before
i think that the idea of biden is why
they want to bring him in because
well biden's a household name he was
part of the old guard he was with obama
and uh this is very much an anti-trump
platform
and uh well the the message of this
campaign will be
returned to the normal and he
essentially represents the past with
this idea biden but
that's the idea the reality is obviously
is very different
with his cognitive abilities declining
apparently quite rapidly
and uh i also agree that there's a
sensor
uh hypocrisy there as well because keep
in mind that the democrats have all for
the last four years now been criticizing
uh the mental state of trump i i would
say quite reasonably
pointing to this narcissism but now
they're running a candidate who is
seemingly struggling with dementia so
it does it doesn't bring up a lot of
moral
issues and for one well what's gonna
it's all about winning now of course but
what happens after he wins
first day of office he's in a he can't
string together a simple sentence
i think uh yes it's gonna be quite
unprecedented before
the rest of his allies especially in
europe they're gonna see
well or one they like more than trump
but also one that's not what qualified
to lead
so and again as you mentioned very much
this empty vessel
yeah well george i mean what the most
one of the most important elements to
keep the international system
stable is certainty what can what can
you
expect i mean in this case i mean when i
look at you know the last three and a
half years
trump on the margins pushed back against
this interagency consensus
but we could have a a man in the white
house in january that will
have no resistance whatsoever it's just
going to he'll sign
you know i'll sign anything i mean that
you know and then who's making those
decisions the bin men's of the world the
unelected bureaucrats um that would
that's going to create a lot of
uncertainty in my mind go ahead
yes that yes and what we've seen um
during the uh trump years and before
is that that that unelected bureaucracy
is
a public menace uh they have been
pushing their
uh agenda they have ignored the elected
president the
the one who actually ran on the platform
they simply said well
you know we don't care about his policy
the policy iran or we
we are the people in charge because as
you say we are the
interagency consensus so um if that was
a dangerous situation
how much more likely would this be under
biden i mean they'll tell brighton well
enjoy yourself have a good time you
don't have to do anything you know
spend time with your family you know you
know playing croquet or whatever you
want to do
we'll run everything um and who are the
people going to be running it i mean
they will be people like
vinman fiona hill uh
all of that that crowd who who kind of
came out of the woodwork
during the uh trump years uh were
quite frightening in their kind of
pathological view of the world
they they would be in charge and and you
know this is a
real serious threat to democracy i mean
what is the point of having elections
if the people who are running it the
country have had nothing to do with any
of these elections they
they didn't run on anything yeah well
they did that's a perfect
good point there because it just shows
the continued divorce between
foreign policy issues and the democratic
process okay
you know glenn one of the things i find
really disturbing is that in the last
three and a half years
trump's foreign policy has been all over
the place i think that's a fair
assessment
but the fact that it's been all over the
place has actually created debate now
mostly against him from the interagency
consensus
but in a biden administration we won't
even have that debate it will it
be as if foreign policy justice is
completely separated off
into a different realm because whoever
is
assuming the oval office in january will
have to deal with the pandemic and
economic turndown
social unrest here and when i worry it's
like what george was alluding to is that
you know going to have the small
you know little cabinet area we'll get
it we'll take care of the rest okay
and you know those people taking care of
the rest have a disastrous record over
the last 40 years
go ahead bud yeah now i would also add
that
what is this going to do to the social
cohesion of the country the trust in the
political class
keep in mind that one of the reasons why
people voted for trump even people who
didn't care much for him is they want to
throw wrench into the system because the
the distrust of the political class and
the media for sake had
grown at a huge level which is pretty
much the definition of populism when
the people feel that alienated from the
political class
now they believe that political class
were too distant
from them and then you have trump in
power and the first thing
they see is the political class
effectively trying to take him down with
this russia gate and
other other ways essentially denying the
results of the election
with hillary obviously leading leading
it
and now once he's uh well he's i
don't care much for the way he leads but
nonetheless by the time he's gone now
they're gonna put in
biden who does not have uh
who seems to have dementia and he seems
to be this empty vessel which
again the the political leads can
control it
for those in the united
this is going to states have a huge
reaction
this time maybe more from the political
right who will question the legitimacy
just like the left
legitimacy of trump the right will not
recognize the
legitimacy really of biden not because
he may didn't fake the election but
because
of his mental state well i mean
we have a political system that is now
rooted in disbelief
okay i mean it is so partisan george and
i have talked about this privately a
number of times
no matter who is declared the victor in
november the country is going to
explode okay there's no doubt about it
in my mind george
we're rapidly running out of time one of
the things i find really um
uh again to the point of bizarre
is that you have this black lives matter
we have you know
tackling systemic racism and all of that
whole narrative that is
in the wake of the of the biden
juggernaut as it were in the basement
but i mean there's no reflection that
the the
american foreign policy for particularly
since the end of the second world war
has has uh dealt very very harshly with
people of color around the world you can
look at southeast asia you can look at
iraq you can look at afghanistan you're
looking at syria
i mean there's no reflection is there i
mean it's all
internal they don't see the how foreign
policy
has been played out to the detriment of
their quote-unquote own
values about fighting racism go ahead
george
yes that's a very very good point that
that's exactly
that kind of absolute hypocrisy oh you
know we really care about you know
people of color
except when they're living abroad i mean
then we really don't care about that
then they just become
uh missile targets so apparently uh
syrians you know they're not people of
color
iraqis they're not people of color you
know we can just bomb them
uh to smithereens but just going back to
uh the
the point about what the agenda of the
interagency consensus
there is no question that these these
people uh
want revenge against russia i mean they
they are furious still over 2016
and one of those dangerous aspects of a
biden presidency will be
uh this crowd that will seek for pay
look for payback
against uh russia i mean and um and i
think that
for what they alleged for based on
allegations a myth and a hoax okay
geez the political left really is a cult
okay
because it's not based on empirical
evidence
it's based on fury resentment
and revenge that's what we might get
in january all right gentlemen that's
all the time we have i want to thank
our my guest in oslo in budapest and i
want to thank our viewers for watching
us here rt see you next time remember
crosstalk rules